need motivation watch a top 10 would
believe nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and this channel was designed to help
you overcome the number one challenge
that is holding you back a lack of
belief in yourself so get ready for some
vision building inspiration from Simon
sonic to give you the motivation
confidence and belief that you need
okay let's kick it off with real number
one follow your vision a vision is an
internal thing right it is the world
that you want to live in right Jobs was
the rebel and he always was against big
business right all the visionaries that
we know have some sort of personal
experience and imagine a world that is
different to the one they live in now
and will use their businesses to help
build that world that doesn't mean
they're the only ones doing it but what
makes them a leader is they're the one
leading towards that place right so
vision has to come from you if you're
the founder of a company your business
is not the only way you do it what have
you quit your business and start another
one it doesn't matter they should all be
contributing towards this vision and
you're not the only one doing it but if
you're the one preaching it and you're
using your company to advance it that
makes you the leader yeah that's what
everybody copies you but it's not about
anticipating the market trend which is
an interest thing you're asking me it's
got to start with values the interest
come second
they're definitely there but they
definitely come sec guys yeah rule
number two be an optimist why are you an
optimist why do you choose to see the
world that way yeah I mean I don't know
if optimists choose to see that way I
think well I guess you can choose to be
an optimist it is it is a point of view
that you can take right you can look for
everything bad in the world and think
the world is crashing and it'll never
get better or you can choose to see the
good in people and choose to see the
good in the world and then that's the
direction that that will follow and you
know I I tend to believe that there's no
finality in anything you know it's not
like you know you're even though we owe
our lives are finite life is infinite
you know life goes on and and for me the
goal is not to produce something that
has an endpoint but to produce something
that
momentum that can live on beyond me and
so I chose an optimistic path rule
number three stop lying
hiding and faking I'm only successful
because of other people I mean in the
early days when I just started my
business I was pretty much convinced it
was me and everyone else was helping me
out you know but I can tell you with
hindsight that the reason my business
took a nosedive because my whole
trajectory changed the first three years
of my business were fun and exciting and
we sort of beat the statistic that you
know the overwhelming number of us
supposed to go to business and I didn't
and my fourth year was very difficult my
fourth year is very different and that's
where you know when you're running on
force of personality where you you're
chief cook and bottle washer you're
making every sales call you're making
you're doing the the product you're
making every you're offering the service
you're doing everything at some point
you reach a level where especially if
you survive for a few years that you now
have to ask other people for help so you
have to hire people right and the stress
of letting go when or trying to do
everything which is demoralizing for
people who you bring on and then needing
structure you know what is the actual
structure of the business it's not just
you doing everything and that's where I
failed I was terrible at structure I
continued to be terrible in deduction
and and really became very very
difficult for me to grow my business
became very very stressful and I really
hit a dark patch and that's when I
learned the most valuable lesson I think
of my career which is I don't have to
know all the answers and when I don't I
don't have to pretend that I do hmm and
a willingness to admit that I needed
help that I didn't know I knew this but
I didn't know that allowed me to seek
help and accept it when I was offered
and I realize I'm we're all surrounded
by people who are plenty willing to help
us but because so many of us spend so
much of our time lying hiding and faking
people don't offer us their help because
they just don't think we need it
yeah because we've presented ourselves
of an in this picture that we're good to
go and so we leave ourselves by
ourselves it's our own fault and so when
I was able to stop lying hiding and
faking and was able to say really good
at this really bad at that
and it wasn't a depressing thing it was
just like an admission mm-hmm people
came up all over go oh my I could
totally help you with that and that's
when my real trajectory took off was
when I
I realized that it's it's a team sport
and I'm I have to be really good at the
thing that I'm good at and I have to be
willing to help those succeed at what
they're good at and allow others to help
me succeed as well at what I'm good at
and so it's that wonderful wonderful
sort of relationship that we all have
each other where we commit ourselves to
seeing each other succeed that is the
reason I find myself where I am today
rule number four start with y so every
single organization on the planet even
our own careers always function on the
same three levels what we do how we do
it and why we do it everybody knows what
they do these are the products we sell
the services we offer some know how they
do it these are the these are the things
we call our unique selling propositions
or you know our differentiating value
propositions and out from the crowd but
very very few people and very very few
organizations can clearly articulate why
they do what they do and by why I don't
mean to make money that's a result by
why I mean what is your purpose what is
your cause what is your belief why does
your company exist why did you get out
of bed this morning and why should
anyone care and what I learned is that
organizations or leaders that start with
by telling you what they do are less
able to inspire people to do business
with them inspire loyalty where those
who start with why whether it's Steve
Jobs or Matt McGann D are able to
command loyalty and are able to innovate
in ways that others cannot and the
reason I say that every company
functions this way is because the model
is not based on some highfalutin
management Theory it's based on the
biology of human decision-making this is
how the brain works that when you start
with Y talks to the part of brain of the
brain that is responsible for decision
making and feelings like trust and
loyalty but it's not responsible for
language which is why it's hard to put
into words whereas the part of the brain
that controls rational like numbers and
products and benefits and features
doesn't affect decision-making also if
you want to have more confidence check
out my 2:54 see
they're free the links join are in the
description below but I'm interested in
your opinion let's go around the room
it's too late the skill to hold your
opinions to yourself
and even though I'm gonna sell you the
most beautiful hammer I'm not gonna
guarantee the structural integrity of
the house I would rather take the risk
of walking out knowing that I might get
moved in a way that I've never
experienced before more than just go and
have a nice night out and see something
that I know is good rule number five be
a problem-solver
I think people misunderstand what the
word entrepreneur means listen you know
small business owners owned small
businesses and entrepreneurs solve
problems and there are many many
entrepreneurs inside corporations yeah
and not all small business owners or
entrepreneurs I see
so an entrepreneur is somebody who's
constantly looking for a better way to
do something there's a there's a sort of
a mad scientist about them it's not
simply you know understanding structure
and building business and and that's the
way I was in the corporate world which
you know depending on my bus was either
welcomed or or not oh yeah I used to get
in trouble for that's not how we do it
around here really did I break any rules
they're like no I'm like did I get it
done they're like yes I'm like did to
get it done better than you expected
they're like yes I'm like so what
exactly is the problem rule number six
be patient
how do you boo trust foster within a
team this is Lee it's how do you fall in
love faster I mean these are these are
like you don't it you know it takes as
long as it takes I hate to say that you
know a you know you can go to the gym
for nine hours but you won't get into
shape but if you go to the gym every day
for twenty minutes you will get into
shape but the problem is I don't know
how long it takes it'll be a little
quicker for some a little slower for
others and so there's no app for trust
there's no app for that you know this is
a human condition and we have to do the
things that are right for human beings
and you won't build trust with everybody
on the team at the same pace some will
be quicker and some will be slower how
long does it take to make a friend you
know I don't know I just know that if
you do the right thing
you will make a friend rule number seven
rage against reality there's a lot of
businesses perhaps some of them are
represented here today we're actually
doing the short-term thing for financial
gain is smart business it is not it is
yeah you do need because you're working
at a public company which reports
quarterly because you need to
keep shareholders on-site maybe you're
worried about losing your job if you
don't hit a certain target in March or
April or May
isn't there a fundamental conflict
between the demands of some businesses
which are short-term interest based and
your vision of business so the argument
you're making is is the argument you're
making is short-term based company
should make short-term based decisions
which means they'll last for the
short-term I'm actually making I'm not
actually making a note of any kind I
just wonder whether or not actually the
reality is maybe this is why you make
the point that I'm arranging against
reality I think that the system's we
have in play do not support capitalism I
think we have corrupted capitalism which
is capitalism at its best doesn't follow
the rules that we follow today the
concept of shareholder supremacy was a
theory proposed by a Harvard professor
in the late 1970s popularized in the 80s
and 90s by basses like Jack Welch right
the concept of using mass layoffs to
balance the books mass redundancies
because we missed our numbers is to the
MIT Romney school - right did not exist
as a standard way of doing business
prior to the 1980s it was a it was
popularized in the 80s and 90s let's
look at the 80s and 90s
these were boom years of relative peace
without the internet right now that
world does not exist we no longer live
in boom times there is no longer
relative peace and the infinite and the
Internet has profoundly changed the way
business operates today in other words
what work then cannot work now GE needed
a three hundred billion dollar bailout
in 2008 because that company was not
built to last what I'm saying is the
systems that we consider normal ways of
doing business shareholder Supremacy
using mass redundancies and other
philosophies and how we incentivize
people how we hire people etc etc they
are outdated and outmoded and they are a
race to zero and the companies that
continue to embrace those philosophies
big or small are struggling with
engagement they're struggling with
innovation they go through people like
nobody's business
and the executives keep getting fired or
quitting right unceremoniously and by
the way their shareholder value is
unstable rule number eight say yes to
opportunities when you talk about what
you believe people who believe what you
believe
recommend you or one introduce you to
people I see and so the more I talked
about it the more somebody would call me
and say hey there's someone I think you
should meet yeah and people found me I
don't know you know from somebody else
so you did not seek out I want to do
this for know yeah so somebody somebody
reached out to me and said we're doing
you know they got my name yeah and they
said we've heard about you we've heard
your work we'd like to invite you to do
a TEDx talk in Puget Sound in Seattle
yeah and I said okay it sounds amazing
you know TEDx was a they were is a
relatively new thing back then and it
was a big deal you know it still had a
lot of real sort of an kind of gravitas
to it and so I was very excited and of
course of course said yes to the
opportunity rule number nine express
your beliefs do you consider yourself a
writer I mean did you where you're
already writing lots of things and tell
us about your process not a writer never
imagined being a writer never fantasized
about being a writer but as I said other
people who believed what I believed I
got very very very good at talking about
what I believed and stopped completely
talking about what I did people come to
say what do you do and I wouldn't say
what I did I would tell them what I
believe and literally I started
practicing the things that I eventually
wrote about which is I started with why
and when you do that it attracts people
who believe what you believe and so the
way the book came about is a friend of
mine who knew what I believed and that
was sharing my ideas with her I said you
have to write this down and I shrugged
and she said I'll introduce you to an
agent and I shrugged and then I had an
agent and somebody else said I wanted to
use you to an editor friend I had and I
tried to said okay and the editor talked
to me he said I wanted to use you to a
publisher so my meeting with the
publisher actually wasn't set up by my
agent and I ended up having a twenty
nine minute meeting with Adrian Zack
Heim who's the god of business
publishing he's the original publisher
from good to great he came up with the
title and everything Wow
and I'm in this twenty nine minute
meeting with him and three days later
they offered me a book deal and I
literally I I never presented myself as
anything that I was not and I just would
tell people what I believed and I'm and
what I imagined the world could be based
on this little idea and people who
believe what I believe wanted I help
and so he helped me by offering me the
opportunity to to share my idea to a
much broader scale he absolutely took a
bet on me and rule number 10 the last
only for very special bonus clip is have
a trusting team a trusting team is an
environment in which people feel safe to
raise their hand and say I made a
mistake I don't feel qualified to do the
job you've asked me to do and I need
more training I need help I'm struggling
at home and it's affecting my work
I'm scared without any fear of
humiliation or retribution or punishment
whatsoever if you do not have trusting
teams inside your organization what you
do have is a group of people who show up
to work every single day lying hiding
and faking you're forcing them to it's
not their fault you're creating an
environment in which people will not
share mistakes for fear that it puts
them on some sort of short list or just
getting in trouble they will not admit
that they don't feel qualified for the
jobs that they have for fear of being
outcasts or again put on some sort of
short list of getting in trouble which
means eventually these things will
compound and eventually something will
break we've seen the results look what
happened with United Airlines we all saw
the film of this poor paying passenger
being dragged off the plane with a
broken nose broken teeth and a
concussion right and I feel for that
crew I do not blame the crew because
they work in a culture in which they
fear making the right decision they
actually fear that they will get into
they believe they will get in trouble
before for making the right decision
they actually fear getting in trouble
more than doing the right thing this was
not an anomaly this has been compounding
over years I had a personal experience
on that airline years prior that was a
red flag I was attempting to board a
plane and one of the passengers this
played out in front of me one of the
passengers attempted to board the plane
before their group number was called
which is all of you know here is a
felony
and that is exactly how the gate agent
treated him step aside sir I haven't
called your group yet please step aside
and wait till I call your group is how
she talked to a paying customer so I
spoke up I said why do you have to talk
to us that way why can't you talk to us
like we're human beings and she looked
me in the eye and said sir if I don't
follow the rules I could get in trouble
or lose my job what she revealed to me
is that she does not feel safe in her
own organization and her leaders do not
trust her to use her own judgment and
they do not trust her
to do the job for which she's been
trained to do and guess who suffers
customer and company the reason we love
flying Southwest Airlines is because not
because they have some magical formula
to hire the best people it's because the
people there feel safe in their own
organization they're entrusted to use
their own judgment and do the jobs for
which they've been trained to do if you
have an excess of bureaucracy in your
organization and I have worked in the
university system and I feel for the
people who abuse me when I go get my ID
because they fear getting in trouble
more than using judgment that is a
cultural problem I do not blame the
person human beings are social animals
and we respond to the environments were
in and ultimately it is the leadership
that is responsible for setting the
environment get the environment right
you get trusting teams get the
environment wrung you are forcing people
to protect themselves from you if you
work in an organization where it is
standard practice for people to feel the
need to send a cya email after every
decision they make cover your ass that
is a sign that they feel that they have
to take time and energy out of their day
away from doing their jobs in order to
protect themselves from you if you work
in an organization where it is standard
practice for people to feel the need
that they have to keep a folder of all
the good things they've ever done just
in case they need it it is a sign that
they feel that they have to take time
and energy away from advancing the just
cause in order to protect themselves
from the organization that's what you
get if they feel safe all of their
energy goes to advancing the just cause
always now I've got a special bonus cup
from Simon on how to be a true
entrepreneur that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that aside with the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to take an
action here we go question number one
what opportunity do you just need to say
yes to number two where do you need to
stop lying hiding and faking at number
three where do you need to be more
patient Elon Musk was just interviewed
by Chris Anderson at Ted last week and
Chris Anderson and sort of near the end
of the interview it's online go watch it
it's really great Chris Anderson asks
Elon Musk's something to the effect of
why are you doing all these things like
why didn't just stick with Tesla and be
done with it
like why do all the other stuff and you
look at and musk you can see this look
on his face and he takes a long time to
answer he actually doesn't understand
the question he cannot understand why
you wouldn't do that and he sort of gets
him Phatak which for you on musk is
pretty amazing cuz he doesn't get him
Phatak but that's basically what it is
he gets some fat again says cuz I want
to live in a world that's better than
this swear words to that effect you know
where I'm not where the world that we're
living right now makes us unhappy why
don't we want to live in a world that
makes us happy
if you want more Simon check that the
top-50 rules video I made on him the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
some people see the thing that they want
and some people see the thing that
prevents them from getting the thing
that they want success is a feeling